[Musique]
peu
il ya plus de 5000 ans les premiers
amérindiens s'installèrent sur cette
terre volcanique et la nommèrent
karukera l'île aux belles joues
[Musique]
il ne pensait pas à la mer ou lagon bleu
les amérindiens vénérait les cascades
les flots tumultueux des eaux
cristallines qui dévale du haut de la
montagne et apporte la vie
[Musique]
la guadeloupe l'île aux belles eaux
compte plus de 300 cascade
[Musique]
certaines sont majestueuses et populaire
d'autres discrète tapie dont l'immensité
verte de basse terre ne se dévoile qu'à
ceux qui veulent bien chercher un peu
[Musique]
oui
carte et boussole solidement accroché au
poignet gérard berry arpente depuis 60
ans la forêt tropicale
hors des sentiers balisés une loi des
traces à la recherche de cascades
il y en a découvert près de 150 voilà
arrivés à bandol la traversée de
lagasnerie guerre qui est un peu plus
délicate est aussi
diplômé en 1980 gérard est le premier
guide de montagne guadeloupéen son
plaisir et d'entraîner les randonneurs
sur les voies qu'il a lui-même tracé
on descendra dans ce cas c'est la figure
une fois passé ici un roman
tranquillement
[Musique]
gérard ne garde pas ses découvertes pour
lui
chaque cascades est un trésor à partir
dans ses pas nous remontons la trace de
la ravine paradis au sud-ouest de basse
terre elle longe la grande rivière de
vieux habitants
[Musique]
où
il ya une équipe dont je ne suis que le
président fondateur qui s'est donné la
mission d'aller découvrir les cascades
puisque nous avons plus de 300 cascades
en guadeloupe mais personne ne le sait
et donc nous sommes dit il faut aller à
la rochelle de ses cascades pour
démontrer que la guadeloupe est vraiment
un pays extraordinaire enfin pour
réceptacle de douces il fallait partir
de la nature quant à l'appui pour aller
chercher ce cas ce qu'a dit son papa
cash est bien loin et souvent
inaccessibles
[Musique]
voilà nos cascades sont dans un écrin
naturel très intéressant mais
c'est la nature avec quelques comptes
nets
il faut aimer laventure parce que
souvent c'est une véritable aventure que
de partir à la conquête d'une casquette
kaki et permettez moi l'expression paumé
au milieu de nulle part parce qu'il ya
des gens qui n'aiment fin qu'il fait
sont
les gars j'ai découvert alors que tout
le monde attendait en forêt on à en voir
le ciel on a du verre
ou du sombre au dessus de la tête mais
ça vaut pour atteindre son but il faut
trouver le passage la petite porte
d'entrée dans cette immensité de verdure
autant d'obstacles à franchir pour
accéder au graal au détour d'un dernier
rocher la belle se dévoile en
voilà il ya traverser cet écrin de
verdure
nous arrivons au paradis
le bassin paradis
sur la rabine paradis la cascade paradis
nous sommes de paradis un boni
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la confidentielle cascades paradis doit
sa réputation à sa remarquable
formations géologiques
[Musique]
le bassin est ceinturé par de superbes
zorg volcanique vestiges des dernières
coulées de lave au 16e siècle
[Applaudissements]
une intense activité volcanique qui a
façonné les paysages tourmentés de
l'agglo bly
la cascade paradis est l'une des
préférées de gérard ici on peut se
ressourcer
chaque cascades à sa personnalité son
rôle son histoire
je suis tombé dedans étant petit si on
peut dire à l'âge de 8 ans j'ai dormi
quelques jours un atout cuillère avec
mon père et à l'âge de 10 ans j'ai fait
la trace victor hugo en trois jours
c'est à duke javea c'est tout le massif
central de la basse terre en trois jours
je me vois que j'avais 10 ans maintenant
c'est moi qui transmet cet amour aux
plus jeunes pour les inciter à découvrir
le pays parce que si on veut protéger le
pays
il faut l'aimer et pour les mecs
reconnaître leur faut sortir de chez soi
il faut sortir de la ville il faut aller
se balader un peu aller se confronter à
la nature qui tue pas toujours forcément
accueille en mai
[Applaudissements]
on gagne toujours quelque chose en
lisant justement bien à 15
j'ai découvert aussi des trains des
cascades sur
et un à la rivière elle est composée de
bronze quatre cadres de bassins de
vasques et c'est génial quand on prend
pour prendre son pied sur les pentes du
volcan lourd hui celle des sommets vers
la mer elle façonne
ce culte les roches à sa guise
s'affranchit des aplombs depuis des
millénaires
[Musique]
chez lui gérard cultive de quoi
documenter son futur musée comme une
invitation au voyage cette pièce est
dédiée aux cartes aux livres aux
articles de presse
ses proches ne partage pas forcément
cette passion débordante
ohlala cette pièce je me fais engueuler
le tabac ma femme parce qu'il ya un
certain désordre apparent cependant
changer quelque chose de secousses et je
n'aime pas que quelqu'un d'autre vienne
y mettre la main mais c'est vrai que ça
fait des années aux plus de 50 ans est
l'élément monde et chose que j'écris des
choses que je récupère des choses qu'on
m'a donné l'élément qui je continue à
récupérer quoi même des choses que je me
suis mis le froid parce que je nourris
l'espoir d'avoir un jour où le temps de
m'asseoir et puis des crues en voit des
choses on n'a qu'à mais suffisament a
écrit et tous les domaines saumon à ya
quelqu'un on va aller au bout
la maison de gérard c'est aussi le point
de ralliement des autres guides de lille
qui viennent le consulter pour préparer
les prochains circuits à gérard alors
[Musique]
cette fameuse ouais ça va se faire au
pied on fait attention elle est comme
moi mais quand est ce que tu fais
l'ancien quand même meilleur demain
alain doit accompagner un groupe de cinq
randonneurs vers la chute du galion
comme souvent dans ces cas là il est
venu solliciter l'encyclopédie vivante
de lire on prend j'ai donné rendez vous
à mes joueurs on est en pleine montagne
belle faut embaucher au contenu des plus
belles cascades forêt magnifique la fois
les bains jaunes vraiment il ya tout
pour perdre
alain a tout appris de gérard comme la
majorité des guides aujourd'hui en
guadeloupe
quarante ans qu'il parcourt l'ensemble
les traces de basse-terre et
collectionne les aventures ici
[Musique]
le lendemain matin au pied de la
soufrière nous retrouvons alain
[Musique]
bombay nous sommes arrivés jaune on va
faire notre randonnée aujourd'hui
arrivée au sud du caire
nous on parle ici les rangs direction à
diaw a dépeint tu vois on va biffer ok
sur la droite pour aller au gagnant à
l'orgue à lyon je vais pas vous raconter
davantage allez vous re découvrir la
chute du galion est l'une des plus
proches du volcan de la soufrière à 900
mètres d'altitude
la randonnée traverse la forêt des bains
jaunes sur un sentier parfaitement
aménagé
[Musique]
élabore des sources chaudes qui dévale
le flanc de la montagne ne pas du roi
sentiers avait du 19e siècle dessert au
fil de l'ascension une multitude
d'itinéraires de randonnée voilà on
arrive à un moment un lieu il faut faire
son choix
nous on va pas la soufrière on va en
gagnant ce réseau de plus de 200 km de
chemins balisés plonge dans une forêt
dense luxuriante aussi fascinante
qu'inquiétante
alors c'est pas la coma c'est un
châtaignier
ah oui ah oui ah oui c'est sûr alors
alors ça comme je disais pour en
connaître c'est ça la finesse ah oui les
feuilles mais c'est pas évident là on
reconnaît bien là feuilles de
châtaignier et puis la résonance ça
résonne à lancer une des éléments pour
bien reconnaître différencier avec la
roma bouquin ici on a une fois que tous
les étages en fait puisqu'on a pas que
les arbres en gros on a partout autour
de soi à tous les niveaux les épiques et
ça pousse partout la présence de l'aude
des arbres tout ça c'est ça fait une
un cocktail détonnant qui fait que du
bien à beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
ah ah là là la pluie menaçante là
attention a sans doute on sentira le
carreau et ne sent bien la forêt +1 le
massif de la soufrière est l'une des
zones les plus humides du monde
340 jours par an la pluie s'impose et
contrarie les ambitions des randonneurs
fait quelques secondes et après on verra
lorsqu'on arrive à la cascade que ça va
me donner encore
[Applaudissements]
au tapis là
cette fois là vers ce n'est que de
courte durée
mais elle va rendre un peu plus
périlleux encore l'ascension finale
il faut se retourner oui et pour mieux
se retourner un peu rassuré l'année
santana
[Musique]
alors on arrive vraiment dans le livre
la du galion
[Musique]
attention on arrive sous des blocs
rocheux
[Musique]
la corde c'est pas du superflu ça vous
permet de rassurer vos pieds à bout de
bras les six randonneurs arrive enfin à
bon port
majestueuse et puissante du haut de ses
40 m la chute du galion impose le
respect
[Musique]
m
alors voyez cette beauté là enfin je
roule cette fameuse cascade comme elle
est belle
comme sur la coque d'un bateau en pleine
tempête des trombes d'eau s'abattent sur
les blocs rocheux
au fil de sa descente la chute perd de
sa force et de son intensité
[Musique]
deux bassins en bassin la cascade se
transforme en torrent puis en rivière
avant de rejoindre la mer où pendant des
siècles est là brevets d'eau douce les
marins en escale
ben voilà neuf hameaux au terme de notre
notre balade le galion pourquoi le
galion autrefois pendant que les galions
les bateaux arrivaient qui s'arrêtait au
niveau 2
de l'embouchure pour aller prendre de
l'eau pour ravitailler les bateaux au
large dans la rade de pas la rade
lancelot goubert sens il ya des bateaux
qui sont là il est 13 ans qui sont
encore dans la mer et la théorie sur le
gâteau aujourd'hui ce beau temps et les
saintes convoi je peux vous dire c'est
bon je peux pas compter le nombre de
fois je suis venu ici c'est rare de voir
les saintes si on le voit mais des
blacks est comme ça serra
très belle randonnée j'aime beaucoup les
voix magnifique parce que dès qu'on fait
une immersion en forêt tropicale c'est
un pur bonheur
et en plus la cascade c'est merveilleux
elle est vraiment très belle façon à 12
points de vue là on est au pied
département tatras d'armistice on a une
ouverture de côté sur cette sauterie via
on se contente de de prendre ce que la
vie nous offre pour faire comprendre la
beauté on prend la sensation bien-être
on prend les odeurs on prend en colère
ou quand la chaleur ou la pluie et c'est
ce sont que des sensations on prend plus
de sensations cet ancien spéciale de
c'est toujours différent et c'est un peu
de bonheur à 4
à l'époque
aujourd'hui le visage d'une tour la
jouvence
[Musique]
l'eau suit son cours et donne naissance
à une nature exubérante
du ruisseau à la source la vie des
plantes s'organise
pour lots nord mirent à cette info
oratoire et le nord
la responsable scientifique du
conservatoire botanique
m
aujourd'hui elle remonte la rivière
jusqu'au chute de morrow
les plus belles cascades et le nord
étudie dès 2000 plantes et 300 espèces
d'arbres qui peuplent cette forêt
sur l'ensemble des deux mille espèces de
plantes vasculaires qu'on peut dénombrer
aux antilles il y en a 300 un petit peu
plus de 340 qui sont endémiques des
petites antilles et il y en a une
trentaine qui sont strictement
endémiques de guadeloupe c'est à dire
qui a trente espèces qui ne pousse qu'en
guadeloupe qu on ne les retrouvera pas
ailleurs dans le monde
là il ya trois beaumier c'est une espèce
d'arbre caractéristiques des forêts
hygrophiles à cette altitude là qui
appartient au groupement
caractéristiques
alors c'est un arbre qui a une histoire
assez importante aux antilles parce que
les indiens caraïbes fouiller les troncs
pour faire des canaux c'est un arbre qui
produit une résine aussi qui est encore
utilisé
d'un point de vue médicinale contre
l'asthme contre les maux de dents aussi
il ya beaucoup d' utilisation
traditionnelle de saint résine les
feuilles au 613 aromatiques et quand on
croise les feuilles
il ya une odeur d'encens très très
aromatique qui s'en dégage qui est très
agréable
bien ancré dans le solide les espèces
végétales se livrent à une course sans
fin vers le ciel tout en les liant
semble vouloir recouvrir la canopée
formé par les plus grands arbres au bord
de la rivière
le tapis de fougères et en ses feuilles
pour capter la moindre parcelle de
l'humour
pour certaines espèces ce gros ce sera
plutôt la fleur qui me séduire à pour
d'autres ce sera plutôt la feuille
puis après effectivement ses capacités
d'adaptation dont quand y'a une plante
qui arrive à pousser dans un milieu
extrême et qui arrive à déployer des
d'une intelligence tels que
ça se voit ça m'épate
au milieu de toute cette verdure parfois
on tombe sur des fleurs très colorées
comme par exemple celle de palets cours
est accro ca de cette espèce là qui est
quand même assez remarquable assez joli
ça c'est typiquement une plante ce qui
mériterait d'être utilisé en plantes
ornementales vont encore faudrait-il
maîtriser sa culture ça c'est une autre
histoire
[Musique]
fasciné par ce temple de la biodiversité
eléonore et soucieuse si les trains sont
ouvertes depuis des décennies permettent
aujourd'hui de mieux comprendre cette
forêt et de rejoindre les cascades
l'homme il laisse une empreinte de plus
en plus profonde dans ces forêts ya
l'impact de l'homme qui est quand même
visible un peu comme partout notamment à
travers les menaces engendrées par les
tracés leur fréquentation
en fait le passage de l'homme sur ses
traces qui sont assez souvent installés
dans les zones les plus stables d'un
point de vue écologique amène à une
érosion de ces zones là alors cette
érosion abouti à un déchaussement des
racines qui du coup fragilise les arbres
qui deviennent beaucoup plus vulnérables
en cas de cyclones ou de perturbations
naturelles
ce armani aussi profondément le sol donc
parfois sur plusieurs mètres
on voit bien que les racines sont à nu
normalement les racines sont
souterraines
on peut imaginer que avant le l'érosion
au niveau de la trace mais le sol
arriver à cette hauteur là quoi donc là
on constate que c'est hyper bout et que
le sol est vraiment remanié en
profondeur et du coup c'est clair que ça
fragilise le maintien mécanique de
l'arbre
la guadeloupe sous faulx d'un paradoxe
bien connu les randonneurs amoureux de
la forêt et des cascades peuvent devenir
une menace pour l'environnement
alors parfois la nature se charge
elle-même d'écarter les importuns
bonjour on va aux chutes jusqu'à nouvel
ordre l'accès est interdit
nous avons eu des infos par des
touristes qui ont été surpris par des
par un glissement de
le blog de pierre dans la chute avec les
ouvriers du parc on va bien nettoyer
bien viens viens on va voir le balisage
et après bon l'accès sera lui ouvert
quand on va évaluer que qu'il n'y a plus
de risque mais on va faire demi-tour
alors voila merci beaucoup pour le front
national
au revoir
[Musique]
face aux équipes du parc national on ne
négocie pas eléonore doit rebrousser
chemin
il n'y avait plus qu'une dizaine de
traversées de rivières et deux heures de
marche à peine pour atteindre les chutes
de morrow mais elles sont inaccessibles
depuis le cyclone
pourrait ouvrir au plus vite le sentier
les équipes du parc national sont déjà à
pied d'oeuvre
[Musique]
ouragans et cyclones aiment venir balayé
cette terre et à chaque fois il faut
repartir de zéro faciliter l'accès aux
cascades tout en préservant jalousement
ce trésor végétales telle est la mission
de ces agents auraient paraît coups de
machette
maxime leblanc commande son équipe
depuis plus de 20 ans non jean hébert
le chantier couper un peu plat mais là
c'est du déblaiement qu'on travaille pas
on n'ouvre pas totalement aujourd'hui en
vo myé pour déblayer un petit peu et
jusqu'à voix et essayer de recueillir le
passage il m'a dit on veut enlever tout
ce qui est des orgies à dieu c'est
naturel a avancé à nettoyer ça vous
pouvez ça allait oui vous fait il pas
plus ici maxime mais dans son jardin et
sa priorité c'est d'anticiper
car cette forêt tropicale se régénère
aux permanences reprend très rapidement
ses droits
[Musique]
bien dégagé les façades et des interdits
donc pour les touristes obligatoires
chacun faisant tout pour qu'on puisse se
peut pas passer gars y voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
c'est ça aussi à beaucoup de diago comme
ça contre pour combler un grand coupé
systématiquement mais les audiences ont
arrêté m on profite et on l'aimé pour
pour éviter que les jeux manchon
ben laden
[Musique]
jusque là aucun nom chaleur hall a mis
la puce à blanzat sabarmati hockey
[Musique]
comment on joue dans les pains de maxime
les plus jeunes de l'équipe sont tous
aussi aux aguets bien d'autres danger
invisible la première vous menacent la
sécurité des randonneurs
[Musique]
oui mais oui c'est en ait à faire au
match
[Musique]
cette armée graminées suite au passage
de
l'ouragan si ils voient boue gêne pas il
va pourrir et ont représenté un danger
éventuel en cas de vente
il peut avoir une orientation sur le
sentier à ce moment quelqu'un peut
passer aussi et donc voilà on cherché à
éviter tout cela donc on n'a pas
uniquement les yeux au sol même bien
alentours aussi voilà depuis le
classement du massif volcanique de
basse-terre en parc national 1989 trois
générations d'agents forestiers tente
d'apprivoiser cette jungle aux abords
des sentiers
on a les plus anciens qui sont là qui
permettent de consommer l'eau sans
oscillons méthode de travail qui ne va
pas être la même en forêt ou lorsqu'on
va être de pique nique la gestion du
sentier savants ou faire passer la
crasse par exemple comment comment faire
des matchs comment monter les marches
voilà donc effectivement c'était
important pour moi aussi à mon arrivée
aux banques de bénéficier de leurs
connaissances et de façon à épouser
pleinement le métier il faut la boe mais
je crois que moi je fais le plus beau
métier du monde
je lui dis souvent en pleine nature et
tout le jeu comme nation étudiants ici
tu dis viaur c'est vraiment moi j'aime
ce que je fais j'aime et un pour tous
les goûts nous avons des coins
paradisiaques
je veux je ne fais pas de comment je
vais pas mollir
mais le plan national on accompagne la
pana
grâce à ces hommes d'ici quelques jours
les chutes de moreau retrouveront leurs
visiteurs
ce monument naturel spectaculaire se
déversent par paliers sur une hauteur de
plus de 100 m
[Musique]
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
les cascades sont un défi
[Musique]
sur ce terrain glissant vous aviez
lennon professeur de canyoning apprend
au bout à se soumettre au courant à se
laisser guider par les eaux
james tape donc on va descendre sous les
rochers là on s'assoit et on se laisse
glisser dans ressortira complètement de
l'autre côté
m
ça va le mans n'a survécu c'est
magnifique en contrebas de la soufrière
un affluent de la ravine du galion offre
aux plus courageux
un parcours extraordinaire jusqu'au
bassin bleu
[Musique]
trouver ses appuis sur les galets au
beau milieu des rapides n'est déjà pas
évident
mais ce n'est rien comparé à ce qui
attend nos aventuriers
voilà venu à moi donc là on est en haut
du rappel de 15 m d'accord c'est le plus
grand rappel notre parcours des
consignes pour la descente
là c'est vraiment verticale donc là
c'est vraiment des petits pas et on
descend tranquillement jusque dans l'eau
si toujours un petit peu de l'émotion de
l' angoisse comme on est là nous en tant
que guide de les rassurer de leur
montrer leur donner des bonnes consignes
pour que tout se passe bien et puis
voilà ils prennent un petit à petit sur
soi et on finit toujours et des grands
sourires et que du bonheur
et un bateau qui coule
temps super nouvelle
ce régal qu'est ce que la nature c'est
un terrain de jeu incroyable
il ya des chemins et l'autre aux banques
il ya tout ce qu'il faut
suivre le circuit sculpté par la
puissance de l'eau oblige chaque membre
du groupe à vaincre ses peurs à se
surpasser
c'est aussi une leçon
[Musique]
la nature est magnifique malgré
cyclone d'une grosse tempête elle se
remet toujours en question là elle se
redéveloppe tout le temps et on a
bio qui est fabuleux le toboggan et le
maintien qui est derrière nous et c'est
à peu près une création à 5000 ans déjà
sur son basalte l'a donc là c'est look
la creuse est loupé à creuser c'est à
cent mille ans c'est très long
à l'échelle géologique sais rien
donc là on arrive à la phase de notre
cagnotte de décence d'accord on met bien
son pied d'appel on envoie loin le
deuxième pied en avant d'accord et on
croise bien les bras au niveau des
épaules vous sentiez pas matière pour
les cantines
super
[Musique]
un nouveau jour se lève sur basse-terre
la lumière matinale est propice à une
relation plus contemplative avec les
trésors de lille
[Musique]
à
on m'appelait
my et
le week-end à mes temps libres 2
peindre sur des zones yves bot comme
celui ci tombe à savoir à l'ail
le fait d'être celle ici
ça même beaucoup parce qu'elle sait à
présent km à évacuer le stress de la
semaine
aussi se sont retrouvés
avec la massue
ça fait un plaisir me fais une petite
bulle en fait donc
à ma belle
[Musique]
et
je suis flatté
parce que
voir
les deux cascades petit de ponzi
cascades et en même temps on fait ce
bois le bafin avec tous ces reliefs les
super beau
plus il ya des années
je peux bien exploitée
c'est
un peu turquoise qui tombe bien le faire
on a aussi des nuances ou rouget
des pierres j'ai poussé un très beau
cadre
[Musique]
pour s'offrir ce moment d'intimité il
faut venir très tôt
difficile de garder pour soi ces petits
coins de paradis ou de ne pas tomber sur
gérard le découvreur de cascades
[Musique]
une mère mais bravo j'ai pas fini encore
du travail
c'est super bon franchement quand il
fait beau
n'est pas le même soleil manquez pas la
même minorité et à chacun des pays
apprendre à les connaître dans un autre
lieu
tellement attachant et de l'apport de
lumière nous laissons elodie à sa
contemplation pour emboîter une nouvelle
fois les pas de girard aujourd'hui il
est accompagné mais nous avons signé
avec - myriam gaillard 6 1 le carré
comme ça tu meurs
un compagnon de marche exceptionnelle
qui a le sens de l' aventure sans
démesure cependant elle ne prend pas de
risques inutiles mais elle peut prendre
des risques calculés
allez un peu partout chercher c'est
pourquoi pour moi c'est une autre
chercheuse de cascades par exemple de
rivière de bassin tous ces éléments aux
forêts qui font de la guadeloupe
le paradis que nous connaissons tous des
sommets et avec myriam ont été utiles
dès qu'on lui a confié une mission est
bien l on peut s'assurer que ça sera
bien bien fait que ça ira jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui gérard n'ira pas à la chasse
aux cascades il va s'arrêter là au point
d'observation des chutes du carbet
vu leur pardonne moi c'est un peu si
c'est pas beau là et ces mêmes jo c'est
chouette
tu vois pas à 71 ans il est temps pour
le patriarche des guides guadeloupéen de
passer le relais au sommet avaient
commencé à descendre
bon je freine des quatre fers en effet d
un homme m donc il est bon d'avoir la
relève et d'avoir déjà un peu plus
jeunes et ils ont cette curiosité qui
est nécessaire pour partir à la
découverte
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui maintient un
peu et ça me permet de leur apporter ce
que je sais et je suis heureux de
constater que eux aussi ils sont
atteints par le virus
[Musique]
les chutes du carbet font partie du
patrimoine naturel de guadeloupe
les offrent un spectacle exceptionnel
mais cache ton corps quelques secrets
gérard en à l'intuition
quelque part dans le secteur une cascade
attend d'être découverte
[Musique]
donc là on a on a un certain nombre de
rabin et je suis fou quand mon temps
entre la deuxième et la première chute
on regarde on a un petit peu on doit
pouvoir en remontant certains certains
cours d'eau de trouver des cascades
quand on fait le tour de la soufrière en
bas on arrive donc plein prétexte ou
c'est que c'est comme les doigts de la
main quoi il ya un nombre de sources de
rabin qui se rejoignent pour former la
grande rivière
on voit bien là on est à 1166 l'année à
là on est à 879 ya vu la chute
aujourd'hui je peux pas aller mais
l'étude mondiale et surtout moi ce que
je te demande de ramener c'est une bonne
photo photo de cette cascade ou de ces
ces quelques cascades que j'aurais
peut-être pas encore vu dans ces cas là
d'accord hockey canadien à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
c'est dans sept zones encore inexplorées
au milieu des 12 premières chutes du
carbet que myriam va se mettre en quête
de la mystérieuse cascade
[Musique]
et
si remonté
découverte
tu seras qu'un plus grand de partir
[Musique]
au pied de la deuxième chutes du carbet
myriam a rendez vous avec quelques amis
[Rires]
gérer en tout à l'heure mady caution
jamais contre les qu'on peut voir
quelque chose
petite cascade exceptionnelles allant d
[Musique]
on randonne depuis tout ça va faire plus
d'une dizaine d'années quand fait avec
e.on par la découverte de choses qu'on
ne pourrait pas faire avec un groupe
avec une association de randonnée par
exemple c'est vraiment du off c'est des
gens qui ont vraiment l'habitude de on
part on se dit pas qu'on va retourner à
telle heure on a vraiment on n'a pas de
limites quoi en fait
avant d'atteindre la rivière recherché
il faut s'attaquer un important dénivelé
passage obligé on souffre mes pensées on
va donc c'est ça l'important c'est de
ces même si la souffrance est grande
mais bon c'est tellement beau à
l'arrivée que on est capable de faire
3 5 heures 3 heures 2 s'offre of 3
heures 5 heures de souffrance
et puis après de rester dix minutes
devant la cascade quoi devant l'objectif
quoi mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
une vue particulièrement dégager ça je
voyais tout à l'heure on a une belle vue
sur capesterre on a une vue sur la
madeleine de côté une grande crête qui
s'appelle la grande chasse aussi donc
c'est énorme
aujourd'hui c'est magnifique
très rapidement notre groupe sort des
sentiers battus pour s'enfoncer dans la
forêt pas nouvelle
après cette longue ascension
myriam et ses amis ont atteint la
rivière longue tôt aucun nuage à
signaler nos chasseurs de cascades vont
pouvoir attaquer la remontée de la
ravine l'esprit tranquille mais ne se
prêtent pas et vaut mieux routes et
chemins et on est encore en vie pour
vivre ou de cabine ou encore jacques
chirac a derrière
et alors que le groupe vient à peine de
s'engager dans la rivière l'intuition de
gérard berry devient réalité
[Musique]
au départ on se fait toujours un
objectif et puis on s'aperçoit en allant
vers l'objectif mais on a toujours on a
toujours des petites surprises comme
celle là où comme on aperçoit déjà
quelque chose d'un peu plus loin et qui
nous intéresse les gens
[Musique]
la cascade par est tout proche mais son
accès des plus périlleux
[Musique]
les rochers sont puissants
le cours enfants
traverser que nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tels des équilibristes
aventuriers se lit sans fin ou sommet de
la rade
[Applaudissements]
ils ne sont plus qu'à quelques mètres du
vol
[Musique]
c'est trop génial on en n oserait la
canne roux est recherché c'est génial
elle est particulièrement intentionnelle
parce qu'elle est très large et très
rares dégâts 50 ans va désormais suivre
les chutes du niagara en fait c'était
facile bien sûr à des mondiaux de
melbourne mais présidial
à l'aise dans la peau d'un balai
allez
mais la photo pour votre bien lu
[Musique]
quel nom meriane ses amis donneront-ils
à cette nouvelle cascade d y penseront
plus tard pour l'instant il savoure le
plaisir d'avoir découvert une nouvelle
merveille de la voiture
[Musique]
oh
dans le massif de basse-terre le bleu de
l'eau vive se mêlent aux verts
pour être aux picards
cascades rivière cours d'eau son
inépuisable source de vie des
amérindiens ont été bien inspiré il ya
un semblant de nommer la guadeloupe car
on perd à une telle zone
m
non
[Musique]
oh